[Müzik]
değerli konuklar Bugün size
Telekomünikasyon ve evren konusunda
konuşma yapmak istiyorum evren ve
Telekomünikasyon İkisi de çok büyük iki
kavram Bugün size
atatürk'ümüzün bir sözüyle başlıyorum
dünyada her şey için Medine'ye için
muvaffakiyet için en hakiki mürşit
ilimdir yukarıda da santia
o da ODTÜ'de her yerde bulunan bir söz
Latince ve aşağıdaki sözün aynısı
efendim
evren ve Telekomünikasyon deyince
bu iki kavramı
şöyle bir bakalım
telekomitasyon ne Telekomünikasyon Sizin
bizim hepimizin içinde yaşadığımız bu
dünyada en fazla kullandığımız şeylerden
bir tanesi değil mi
telekomünikasyonsuz Bir Hayata
düşürebiliyor musunuz
unutmayın Siz değil sizden önceki
nesillerde hatta hatta ilk çağdaki
insanlar da
bir şekilde Telekomünikasyon
kullanıyorlardı ya dumanla ya davulla ya
borosanna bayrakla
şimdi ama bunları kullanıyoruz
Samuel mors bize 1835'te
Telgrafı buldu
1855'te
hemen sonrasında telgraf Osmanlıya girdi
o tarihlerde
uluslararası telgrafçılar Birliği
kuruldu telgraf her şeyin başıydı
Atatürk'le dedi Kurtuluş Savaşı'nı biz
telgraflar kazandık
şimdi telefon var İnternet var
pini yeni şeyler var İnternet of Things
konuşuyoruz nesnelerin interneti
konuşuyoruz metabors Konuşuyoruz
blockchain konuşuyoruz internet tabanı
iletişim konuşuyoruz
Hepimiz evlerimize daha geniş bantlı
haberleşme istiyoruz Çünkü biz
haberleştikçe mutlu oluyoruz
gelin Bunlar neler Bunlar bakınız
birkaç tane örnek en sağ alt köşede
gördüğünüz yazı aranızda tanıyan çok
azdır
en sağ alt köşede gördüğünüz cihaz
NT 450 Araç telefonu
Bendeniz telekomikasyon alanında birkaç
tane
ilklerin içinde bulundum
telekomünikasyondaki ilk tip onay
laboratuvarın kurucu mühendisi
kurucu müdürüydüm nemli telefonları Ben
test ettiğim zaman ancak Türkiye'ye
giriyordu Bu eğlence telefonlar elimden
çok geçti onun yanında hepimizin
dinlediği radyo var
vesaire antenler şunlar bunlar gelin
daha bu işin teknolojisine biraz daha
gidelim
mobil telekomünikasyonu ele almak
istiyorum hepimizin elinde
cebinde kullandığı şey ilk telefon 1G
Biraz önce bahsettiğimiz NT 2G 3G 4G
şimdi 5 köy konuşuyoruz şu anda 4K sizin
telefonlarınızda 4.5g diye geçiyor
4g'de bakınız Biz telefonu artık bir
yarı bilgisayar haline getirdik 5g'de ne
var 5 kere de bir mikro saniyeye bir
gecikmeyi otonom cihazlar için
vesaireler diye konuşuluyor ya ben her
ne kadar o işe çok katılmasam da
5G de Cihazımız artık çok az Geciken çok
hızlı tepki veren ve çok daha Geniş bant
içeren bir cihaz polar koordinatları
kullanan ki bulucusu bir Türk bildiğiniz
gibi bir cihazdan bahsediyoruz 5G ile
her şey aslında değişiyor bakın burada
sıralamayı verdim size
2 kilo bitten geldiğimiz nokta 10 GB
Bütün bunlar yatırımla yapılıyor Bütün
bunları yapmak için yatırıma gereksinim
duyuyoruz Türkiye'de Telekomünikasyon
sektöründe
durumumuz bu
5G dediğimiz şey sadece baz istasyonları
ile çalışmıyor
arkasında baz istasyonları merkeze
bağlaması gereken bir fiber optik
kabloları gerekiyor
Türkiye'de olması gerekenin beşte
birinde
Bütün bunların hepsi ne yazık ki yanlış
özelleştirme politikaları
özelleştirme yanlış demiyorum
özelleştirme politikaları Yanlış diyorum
bu geldiğimiz noktayı gösteriyor
Türkiye 80'lerde dünyanın en iyi
Telekomünikasyon altyapısına sahipken
bugün geriye gidiyor
insanlığın ilk tarihinden beri
Roma'da
Aslında Suriye'de
evren konusunda çalışmalar başladı
evreni hepimiz merak ettik Evren çok
önemliydi şu gün Geldiğimiz noktada
einstein'dan biri biliyoruz ki evlen
genişleyen büyüyen bir kavram
Telekomünikasyon bu kavramı anlamak için
de yoğunlukla kullandığımız güzel bir
unsur
her uzay aracı
atıldıktan sonra atılırken
Öncelikle
komuta ve kontrolü için Telekomünikasyon
sistemlerine ihtiyaç duyuyor Ama daha
sonra içindeki her türlü bilimsel ürünle
her türlü bilimsel üründen aldığı veya
cihazın aldığı bilgiyle
o bilgiyi yer merkezine aktarmak için
yine bir Telekomünikasyon sistemine
ihtiyaç duyuyor evreni biz nasıl
tanımlıyoruz evden Aslında bizim
yaşadığımız şu İçinde bulunduğumuz
büyük dünyanın da içinde bulunduğu Güneş
sisteminin içinde bulunduğu
Samanyolu'nun içinde bulunduğu her şey
Evren etrafımızı saran her şey
Yıldızlar arası boşluklar diğer
galaksiler diğer Yıldızlar diğer
gezegenler Evren hepsi Bizim gördüğümüz
ki 13 buçuk milyar ışık yılı öteye kadar
görebildiğimiz varsayıyoruz
göremediğimiz her şey Evren
Güneş sisteminde biz bunları anlamak
için uydular atıyoruz bakın
peynir ilk attığımız uydu 73'te atmışız
yerküreye uzaklığı 107 astronomik birim
boya içer boya içer 2 Bunlar ikiz olarak
gönderildi 77 yılında
Voyager Bey şu anda en uzakta olan sonda
Ne kadar uzakta tamiri de var mı
aranızda
Voyager 70 yılı 7 yılında atılan ve
saniyede
16.9 kilometre hızla
ki bu kabaca herhalde
35.000 55 bin kilometre hıza tekabül
ediyor
bugün Dünyada ne kadar uzakta Voyager
bugün dünyadan 24 milyar kilometre
uzakta
yukarıda gördüğünüz çanak anten yüksek
kazançlı anten dediğimiz şey dünyaya
bakıyor
diğer tarafı sondanın diğer
enstrümanları ne ki onlar
radyoteroskobu var çeşitli
elektronik cihazları var caylas grubu
var vesairesi Bunlar da gittiği yöne
bakıyor
yüksek kazanç anteni sürekli bizimle
irtibat halinde
Biz Peki hangi antenle bunu görüyoruz
bu kadar uzağa giden şeyi Biraz sonra
onu da Göstereceğim size
bir dips Space station'ımız var bizim
onunla görüyoruz 3 tane ayrı bölgede
bakınız
bize gönderdiği sinyal bu iki nokta
Sekiz kilo biterse kıtlık bir sinyal
gönderiyor Ne kadar küçük bir data
haftada gönderiyor ve bunu 3 kez
kaydediyor yolluyor Çünkü
kaydetmesi lazım ki her dakika
yollayamaz Bu bir enerji israfı olur
Bunun dışında biz ne yaptık
bir en son bunu attık biliyorsunuz yeni
2022'de yeni nesil uzay teleskobunu yeni
nesil uzay Teleskobu
bakınız
şunları gönderiyor James web bir buçuk
milyon kilometre
mesafede Laguna 2 noktasında
ve ikisinin bize gönderdiği datalar
aynı Bizler gibi Uzak araçları da
teknolojik geliştikçe daha fazla bant
genişletiyorlar 400 GB
haftada artık Bize gelen veri
işte bunları Biraz önce söylediğim yeni
nesil bir sistemle getiriyoruz dips
Space optikal komitation Center bunu
2021 Ocak ayında Bir Uzay yürüyüşünde
uzaydaki
istasyona da koyduk
insanlık olarak konuşuyorum tabiatıyla
ve Bununla artık daha Yüksek hızda daha
kesintisiz daha geniş bantlı iletişimler
kurabiliyoruz Böylece James Web'den
gelen
yüksek çözünürlüklü görüntülen hepsi ele
alınabiliyor şu anda bu
istasyonlar 3 yerde var bir tanesi
Amerika'da Kaliforniya'da diğeri
İspanya'da maddi
en sonda da Avustralya'da kambera'da
Böylece bu yayılım ne 120 derece açıyla
hiçbir zaman kesinti olmuyor
diye bir şov var orada bir
Evren yaratılmış küçük bir toplum
yaratılmış ve yaşayan Truman orada da
hiçbir şeyden habersiz bebekliğinden
itibaren orada yaşıyor ve en sonunda iki
bir noktada yelkenlisi
kendisinin gökyüzü sandığı
kumaş parçasını deliyor
Aslında o gün bir sahne içinde bir Koza
içinde olduğunu düşünüyor
ben sizlere soruyorum
acaba
Biz de Truman gibi bir Koza içinde
yaşayan
Tırtıllar veya Kelebekler miyiz
Ne dersiniz teşekkür ederim beni
dinlediğiniz için